Before creation itself there were six singularities
Forged into Infinity stones
Hey everybody its charlie, hopefully you've had a chance to see infinity war once or twice by now
This is gonna be my video explaining how the soul gem works
And why the Thanos theory you know th a NOS theory ended up being correct just not in the way that everyone
Expected so obviously spoiler warning if you haven't seen infinity war yet
There's a new round of the Infinity Gauntlet giveaway too that I'll explain at the end of the video
most of you are probably familiar with it
but if you've never heard of the Thanos theory of the
Location of the Infinity stones that was mostly what it referred to like where the stones popped up it
Started to percolate after phase two after we had seen a couple of stones people like wait a minute
t for tesseract a for aether and
for necklace of the time stone o
For the orb of the Power Stone s for the scepter of the mine stone so for the longest time people were wondering what H?
Meant and this theory actually started before dr.
Strange so we didn't know that n was necklace people were like wait a minute the Marvel movies are
Continuing to verify this theory so everyone was just expecting that H would pan out as something like Heimdall
But after thor ragnarok it was confirmed no soul gem anywhere to be found
We got the Black Panther and people were like okay. Wait a minute
Maybe it's gonna be heart-shaped or maybe it's gonna be the heart tree of
Wakanda then Ryan Coogler came out and was like I love the Infinity stones he's a huge lifelong comic book fan
Just like James Gunn, but he was like we already had vibranium
we felt like that was special enough so obviously for Infinity Ward they fabricated a
completely new backstory for the soul stone in the Marvel Cinematic Universe
to make it part of the emotional through line for Thanos as part of that big twist with Gamora to prove that Thanos wasn't just
A mustache twirling villain he was capable of loving something they wanted to make you feel that
Sacrifice in the price that he would pay so we'll get to the mechanics of the soul stone in a second because it's a big
hat tip for what's going to be happening during Avengers 4 a
Sacrifice that the Avengers will eventually have to make to wield it
But if you're not a big comic book reader the powers of the soul stone
Have to do with
Controlling souls as the name implies pretty easy slam dunk there it allows the person who wields it to capture the souls of people
Preserving life after death that's a really important idea it also has the ability to devolve living beings
Which is where you get to the ash people at the end of infinity war so when people are turning to ash
That's Thanos using the powers of the soul stone
Amplified when used in conjunction with the power stone the space stone the reality stone in the Mayan stone so remember
There's a stacking bonus from using the stones together so for instance he uses the time stone to turn
Vision back so that he can take the mine stone from him before he exploded
but Thanos could actually roll time back or
forwards for the entire universe if he used the time stone with all the other stones together
so we know there's a lot of separate questions about how the
Avengers are going to fix everything and bring all those ash people back because I do
Think that all the ash people will come back
I just don't think it's gonna be the way that people expect
But even though the stone was on Vermeer the reason why the Thanos theory is still correct
There's actually three reasons why it's still correct one the planet for me or where they find
It is inside the hel gent our system
Which is inside Kree controlled space remember that for Red Skull stuff Avengers for Captain Marvel?
That'll come back around later when we talk about the history of red skull
After he got ported into space by the space stone like what was he doing that whole time?
He said he was searching for stones Ian's a part of the galaxy where Captain Marvel is popping up
But number two you could also say that H stands for Hydra since Red Skull is the guardian of the soul stone?
They're sort of combining a couple different ideas here when he pops up because he's meant to represent the aspect of death
But he's also the guardian of the soul stone as if the soul stone captured his soul and he's now prisoner to it
But if you were wondering ladie death doesn't appear anywhere in the Infinity war movie they confirmed that last week before the movie came out
They're like we didn't use her as a character so Red Skull is the closest thing that you get to the aspect of death?
But the age of the Thanos Theory also
Applies to the mechanics of the soul gem in the price that you have to pay you have to give your heart to it
So to speak like fan OHS has to give something he loves something that he cares about trading a soul for a soul
Remember, there's a big Avengers line. We don't trade lives
That'll come back around during Avengers for it, too
But they knows trades at Gamora soul in order to wield it
Which is why at the end of the movie when he goes into that special place?
I think that that is the soul world Gamora will come back during Avengers 4 even though
It seems like she died like they wanted that big emotional moment
They wanted you to feel it, so they're not gonna talk about it for a long time
But the actress Zoe Saldana did an interview where she said she was going back to film scenes for Avengers 4
Can you tell us if your infinity war in the middle of it?
I think that the Guardians just shot their part when it comes to
Infinity Wars like the first part and we all have to go back for gauntlets later
this year
Most people saw that and they were thinking more about what the title of Avengers 4 would be not the fact that she would have
Died during Avengers 3, but still come back during Avengers 4 so two reasons why that interview is important
But when red skull tells Thanos that there's a certain wisdom that comes with wielding the soul stone properly
He's talking about the price you have to pay like when little Gamora asks him inside the soul world
Did you do it was it worth the price? He looks at her sadly and says yes little one
I don't think he totally understands where he is he might comprehend it, but think about it
This way the soul world
Contains the souls of certain people now it might contain the souls of all the ashed
People - that was an immediately evident from that Thanos scene, but it is a logical explanation
And it is how the gem works in the comics so you can use some of the comic book explainer?
But obviously they've changed the plot of the comics quite a bit
But what happens when someone tries to wield the gauntlet incorrectly so the stones work together?
But in order to wield the soul stone you have to sacrifice something
You love you have to feed it a soul so what if somebody just put the gauntlet on and tried to fix everything
Usually what happens in the comics is is either one of the stones will crack?
It'll break like it'll kind of melt it at the end of Infinity Ward not completely broken
But it looks like Thanos is gonna have to wait a little while before he uses it again
But also the stones can scatter themselves across the cosmos, but here's where we get into Avengers for territory
How do the Avengers fix everything do they go back in time do they just use the gauntlet to wish everything back?
Because you could do that too, but the problem now is that the gauntlet looks like it's damaged
And I've talked about why I think that
Ironman is gonna be the one to wear the gauntlet just because of that parallel arc that they put him in Thanos on he respects
Him Captain America is somebody who's also worn the gauntlet in the comics spider-man has even had the gauntlet
But he's been turned to ash
so he's probably not gonna be a really big character during adventures for think about who's still alive at the end of the movie and
Who had the most emotional moments with Thanos?
Aside from Gamora so Iron Man probably had the biggest scene with him there were a couple really important gem related scenes during
Infinity war one. There was Shuri
Examining the power of the mine stone she did some work
But obviously she didn't finish with vision he ended up dying anyway. That'll come back around
There are a couple of characters like ant-man and the wasp they're gonna be going into the quantum realm during their movie
What can you do with the Infinity stones?
You could actually travel inside them so when they come back their powers will also be useful for examining
What's going on inside the gems then there's the way the movie leaves?
Thanos at the end of Avengers 4 because even if his arc is done you have to have some way to wrap him up so
That he's not a loose thread just traveling through the galaxy if he's alive at the end of Avengers 4
He could always be a threat and come back so you have to resolve that in some way
The easiest way to deal with him is to trap him for all eternity
Inside the soil world the only way to do that
Would be if Gamora is the one to willed the Infinity Gauntlet during Avengers 4 so?
Alternate theory the only way they completely deal with Thanos
Henceforth is to have Gamora come out of the soul world somehow like Ant Man goes into the quantum realm during ant-man the wasp
What if they travel into the soul stone to bring her back out, but let me know in the comments?
How do you think they rescued Gamora from the soul world and what do they do with Thanos at the end?
because of the end of comic book Infinity Gauntlet
Thanos became part of the Infinity watch he kind of went from being a villain
to being more of an
antihero type person so if Thanos doesn't do that at the end of Avengers 4
They had to do something to resolve him because I don't think they bring that character back during phase 4 phase five
Maybe not even during phase six like however many phases
They're gonna make I think that Thanos isn't going to come back for a long time
But there'll be a whole bunch more infinity war posting in the next week obviously Captain Marvel stuff
I'll do a new red skull video sometime soon after more people have a chance to see the movie
It's still a little spoilery, so I'm not gonna put him on the thumbnail for this video even though
I probably should but there's a new round of that Infinity Gauntlet giveaway all you have to do to enter is be a subscriber
Leave a comment on the video click here for my full review of the movie and click here for my post credits scene video
Thank you so much for watching. Everybody stay awesome. I'll see you guys tonight